gentleman swansong how you livin yes
wine showing the snakejuice I'm more of
a whiskey man
Ron Ron come here come here for a bit
you're good right there listen you got a
jump on the Tommy time Express this guy
is some of the best investment ideas
I've ever heard in my life make a baby
tuxedo clothing line a department store
with the guestlist white fur earmuffs
for men contact lenses that display text
messages embed a phone that smells good
own a nightclub called Eclipse that's
only open for one hour two times a year
cover charge $5,000 I can keep going oh
my god
did you put glitter in the laundry
detergent oh yeah I'm experimenting with
some new entrepreneurial ideas that
one's called Sparkle suds tres loud will
you stop putting glitter in everything
this morning put glitter in the butter
disco dairy spray the park no that's not
a good idea that's terrible
well the target demographic isn't angry
middle-aged nurses Miss wicks if you've
read our proposal you'll see that an
alliance between rent-a-swag and
sweetums could be mutually beneficial
well I must say it's a much better idea
than the last one you had that gourmet
French food thing
oh my escargot delivery service snail
mail so you want to partner up and make
history if you let Newport have the vans
that just sit there and a lot if you let
us have the band's they drive around
town all day free publicity everyone
will see your logo which is you all
pressed up on some chick with huge cams
yeah it's a hell of a day people need to
know about it and I don't need free
publicity I can just pay for it with my
$10,000 look I can go try to play a
player you trying to get beaucoup bucks
just like the rest of us so how about
this I have a business idea for a
gourmet alcoholic yogurt I call it
yogurt platinum I'll let you in on the
ground floor and let me tell you it's
gonna be worth way more than 10 grand
yeah but now that I know your bad idea I
can start the company myself with my
$10,000 no you can't do that Ron Tom
Donna could you please give us a moment
I'd like to talk to Bill man
he's gonna steal yoga Platt no I'm not
okay Tom I want you to take Ben and make
him go to that antihistamine party it's
allergic and forget it he doesn't know
anybody in town come on Tom take him
under your tiny little wing he's a fully
grown man Leslie it's nice just not
about pleasure
I'm smooshing Dennis Feinstein so I'm
gonna put you my new Cologne
tell me fresh okay well while you're
doing that I want you to picture Ben in
his motel room all by himself with no
friends staring at the wall deal
Tom so what's your plan wait till he's
alone then I walk up and spray him with
Tommy fresh and I say uh-oh looks like
you just inhaled your future yeah that
might actually work okay how about this
one
LASIK for fingernails you cut your
fingernails once never had to cut them
again all we need is a complicated laser
I have no idea how to build seems
impossible
all right well salt Wiens saltines for
tweens seems unnecessary this is
actually a crazy coincidence I have a
new company and could use your help on
the math side of things
Oh what's a new company we specialize in
making stacks on stacks on stacks on
stacks right pass I'm kidding it's a
real idea so get this kids are always
growing out of their clothes so their
parents don't want to buy them nice
thinks I'm gonna rip my upscale clothing
to middle school kids because I
discovered I'm roughly the same size as
the average Pawnee twelve-year-old it's
actually a really great idea I know can
you take a look at the business plan to
what you think sure why not awesome I
want to open up my own club one day
maybe called something like club a dub
dub or the club marine sort of a
submarine themed club or Tom's Bistro
the word Bistro is classy eight Tom and
we are looking for a few top-quality
guys like yourself to become part owners
guy like you with your political
connections I think you'd make a great
asset which I agree that's why I got
into public service to help me all right
ten thousand dollars to share even money
by Friday
ten thousand dollars is chump change
I will see you Friday with $10,000 all
right partner
no one else brought me any good business
ideas so I decided to take care of it
myself
talking tissue each time you pull one
out you get a little message to hype you
up
well that nose player know the stinks
just gonna have to go back to my same
job that I've had forever
here's a sitch I developed a dope new
game show where I ask couples scandalous
questions and they have to guess what
the other one answered
I call this know you boo oh that sounds
like the newlywed game shut up Jerry
it's not the newlywed game okay what do
jay-z little Wayne and Drake all have in
common
oh I know this one they are all rapid oh
my god the rapper's Jerry what they have
in common is none of them have ever
performed in Pawnee why because we don't
have an adequate concert venue until now
the Pawnee amphitheater how much would
that cost not that much 200 300 million
great great I need you guys to come to
the snakehole lounge tonight to help me
with something
yeah no tonight's no can do I'm on a
cleanse this is important I'm watching
my new high-end Kahlua star liqueur
snakejuice sounds like you took a snake
and twisted it like a rag until its
blood and guts came out hey
what is Kahlua style mean I mixed a
bunch of alcohol together add some sugar
and coffee and a mother junk and it can
taste like cooler I can only drink warm
tap water with cayenne pepper fine then
don't drink it just get other people to
drink it okay meeting in one hour if you
don't make it you're on my dunzo list
Tom I just want to say that you are a
wonderful employee and a terrific human
being meeting adjourned
I enjoy you you know what else I enjoy
your entrepreneurial spirit I did
recently sell my Chronicles of Riddick
DVD on eBay for $10 use the profits to
buy the blu-ray sir huh what's Leslie up
to well I don't think I should discuss
that given that you're in
petition need to remain neutral fair
enough
Terry what's Leslie up to she is trying
to find a historical reason to earmark
the land for preservation Harry come on
man
Leslie you little snake if Leslie's gone
for a hook we should too let's get
Annabel bloosh person yes
glad to see finally come around after
these two minutes of insanity now will
you please consider investing in that
toddler come on I've been bugging you
about toddler clone baby just you smell
good
this is it for certain okay I create a
game show to people on stage right they
flip a coin one of them has to perform
open-heart surgery the other one has to
receive open-heart surgery we call it
open-heart surgery how about this you
buy a Gulfstream g4 jet already
interested take the wheels off get them
off of there turn the jet into an
apartment building people could live
inside their own private jet
we're currently coming up with business
ideas for John Ralphie Oh cuz as of
today his bank account is blowing up I
made my money the old-fashioned way I
got run over by Alexis I still can't
believe you want all that money in the
lawsuit you barely got hurt at all do
you want to get run over because I know
a guy super gentle minor scrapes and
bruises major dollars and cents I got it
what are you amazing yet I know it we
both know it let's just say it at the
same time creating spectacles no I got
it
you create pawnees first and only
high-end all media entertainment
conglomerate absolutely that's
absolutely what I have to do what does
it mean it means audio video movies 3d
movies nightclubs iPhone apps if it's
entertainment you're involved yes of
course I am and you call it
entertainment 720 no why why you got to
stop screaming oh well I just get
excited why do we call it entertainment
720 cuz you're willing to go around the
world twice for your clients yeah I
think we can do that for a million okay
we'll talk soon there was no one on the
other end of that phone call but soon
there will be welcome to the
Dreamatorium
aka the headquarters of entertainment720
we got a pool table a ping-pong table a
couch through the ceiling on it in-house
DJ
once and best of all former NBA
superstar Detlef Schrempf is on retainer
what's up Detlef
what is this business do again it's a
multimedia entertainment production
conglomerate well I don't know man you
have a lot of overhead here ever thought
about scaling back a bit and focusing on
building your client base
thanks a lot forms magazine but we
didn't hire you to give us business
advice we hired you to look pretty and
shoot baskets so aren't you head over
there and do you think you want people
to see you when they come in dead last
big deep hit me we're living the dream
Mitch thanks for meeting me my pleasure
it's not often that I see someone with
your spark of an passion that's what
makes businesses work passion so mr.
Haverford let's get to it what idea you
passionate about I got two words for you
Tom's Bistro an old-fashioned old-world
Italian restaurant classy authentic
ambience in a small town setting why
does that say dry cleaning chemical
transactional holding company Ben you
brought the wrong easel God you can't
take this guy in
you